okay so thank you very much so maybe I
should have printed the old in a larger
font and the new in a smaller font but
uh it is
capital oh that's true yeah thanks
arish um first of all I should state
that it has nothing to do with IG values
yeah so I'm talking of Spectra it has
nothing to do with IG
values okay so this was the point when
we would expect half of the audience to
leave
immediately
okay so
uh turned
off okay so um what's the agenda for
today so first I want to introduce the
ASM totic spectrum of of tensors and its
relation to matrix multiplication in
particular I will spend the first few
slides on really basic stuff on the
exponent um of matrix multiplication and
F matx multiplication so don't don't
worry Chris I will not grab away too
much from your
talk and um I will really spend all
stuff on the basic things because that's
what's lying at the heart of everything
and you you once you start with this ASM
totic Spectrum you forget about
everything but it's really important
because it's underlying everything and
this is essentially based on a sequence
of three papers by Fen so around 1987 to
1991 and um essentially this concept of
ASM totic spectrum is not that well
known you of this papers you know the
laser method maybe that so that's what's
known but the rest is it's rather
unknown um maybe one reason for this is
that I have the impression somebody told
th in 196 86 that category theory is a
cool thing yeah so and um uh so
therefore it's it's not so accessible
but uh uh yeah I I'll try to present it
in a in in a very uh basic way
underlying everything um are so-called
Stone pre-orders I will Define what this
is and um so the second part of the talk
this was Will is based on some um
unpublished work with Manu aora who's
now a post by Chris Hum group and um so
we are currently or at least I am
currently in the process of writing
everything up so uh not every it's not
not completely finished and essentially
there we try to um find stronger
pre-orders for which you can study asmic
Spectra and stronger pre-orders um they
have the property that uh you might get
better algorithms yeah you have more
algorithmic tools at your hand on the
other hand this is an unpublished idea
that Str told me last year so I will
just very briefly sketch this because
it's not my idea you can also look at
Via pre-orders then the math gets easier
and it's much much easier to determine
this ASM totic Spectra yeah so these are
the two possibilities uh that we have
our hand now and the first I will
introduce the ASM totic Spectrum then I
talk about our approach and if there's
still some time left in the end I will
just briefly talk about about st's idea
and if even more time is left then you
will have a longer
break so that's the problem that's lying
uh Beyond be under under everything yeah
it's matrix multiplication you know all
that we have two matrices we want to
compute a product it has the usual
formula the entries are variables and
our allowed operations are these basic
arithmetic
operations and
um what will also play an important role
later on there's str's algorithm yeah
this is this way of multiplying 2 by two
matrices you know these um seven
products here and you can write the
entries of the uh the
result as linear combinations of the
seven products
yeah it's not obvious but you can do the
calculations yeah seven is out of order
seven is out of order no no no no he's
asking me an obscure
question I see
okay I'll tell you I yeah so sorry I
couldn't
come I wanted to come so um and um so St
that's the B the whole story so you
trade seven multiplications uh so you
you have 18 additions so you trade one
multiplication for 14 editions and uh so
the question is of course what's this
good for and the observation is that Str
algorithm works over any ring so you can
do this this block structure thing you
cut your 2 N by two n matrices into 2 by
n byn
blocks and then you can just recurse and
then you get this recursive inequality
and you get a result that you can
multiply n byn matrices uh with order 2
to the n. 81
multiplications that's
uh and that's now where where Tor rank
comes into play so this is just very
concrete we here in the first part we
will just work with coordinates and
everything yeah so so so some bases
showed up and I will just take them so
um we have some bilinear forms in X
variables and Y variables and we we
write down this triline your form here
and then these structural constants
there um they just form our tensor and
then we can uh reformulate
um the question uh with some B set of
bilinear forms has a certain bilinear
complexity as a tensor rank problem I
also have seen this before so we have
this is Our Ambiance space we have this
Triads they they are the rank one
tensors and then the tensor rank is the
smallest R such that they are rank one
tensors T1 to tr R such that I can write
my T as the sum of these
tensors and two important properties of
tensor rank is um yeah so we can um
perform the direct sum of two tensors so
as a picture it looks like this and what
you algorithmically should think about
this is uh so you have matrices A and B
and matrices c and d and you want to
compute this independent
multiplications and um then we know that
the rank is a sub aditive and for the
rank it's no problem whether it's
additive yeah so so can it really
help to multiply a * B when you also
know that you multiply C * D in parallel
and but for the concept of Border rank
this really helps there's an example by
TR which we will also see later on so
for Border rank
um it's really strictly sub additive and
for for rank it's an open prop that's TR
additivity conjecture and the other
thing is when you perform the tensor
product of two tensors it's also sub
multiplicative so um for just abstract t
for concrete tensors tensor product
somehow looks like this but for matrix
multiplication we have the important
property that if I take the tensor
product here of um two Matrix
multiplications I get a matrix
multiplication again that's uh very
important and just to make sure that
everybody has seen a matrix
multiplication tensor so here's the tens
of 2x2 matrix multiplication and it
looks like this yeah so um the third
dimension is colorcoded yeah so we have
a blue layer a red layer a Green Layer
and a gray layer and so this tensor just
you have a 2 x two identity Matrix in
every layer and you just shift it into
all the four possible
positions and um in general it's given
by uh by this formula the entries where
Delta is chronicus
Delta and if you now um look from the
top of this t or you look from a side on
this tensor you will see that you will
always see a matrix tensor yeah so um
the rank of a matrix tensor it's
invariant on permutations yeah but also
you just can compute the dimensions of
the metrices so these are the two
important things about metrix
multiplication when whenever the rank
you know the rank of say us maybe I
didn't tell you so this is just this
thing is the tensor of K * m matrix
multiplication with M * n matrix
multiplication yeah just the usual
notation and um
so just by looking at the pictures and I
look at the different sides on this
tensor you'll see that uh so this uh no
matter which which thing you you will
take um whether you want to multiply K
by n matrices with M * n matrices or you
want to multiply n * K matrices with K *
n matrices the rank is the same we
always get a matrix
tensor nowadays it looks trivial but
there's no paper by hcra mosinski where
they do the the explicit calculations
over 20 Pages or something like this
yeah so it uh it really took some time
until until one saw um this picture
behind everything
yeah and um then essentially you can you
have the observation if you take 10 the
product that's just recursion yeah so
algorithmic idea of this tensor product
is recursion and then you can just say
just take stress algorithm you form a
huge tensor power of it is and then you
get 22ds Times by 2 tods by 2s matrix
multiplication no that's everything
that's the algorithmic ideas behind
everything
and then you know that this is bounded
by seven to the S and then you could do
the calculations and uh you will see
that you can do matrix multiplication in
order 2 to
2.81 and that's
the the usual definition of matrix
multiplication exponent so Omega is just
the INF over all to such that the rank
of the N byn matrix multiplication tens
is bounded by bounded by n to the TOA
and by this thing here and the sub
additivity and Sub multiplicativity of
uh of rank we get that this exponent is
bounded by 2.81 so that's the whole
story behind
everything
okay and so for now on we just will um
concentrate on
tensors and um it's very important so
these tensors they live in some some
ambient space u uh tensor V tensor W and
in the first two slides I will just uh
write them explicit to every tenser but
you should always keep in mind that they
live in some of space they could for for
the same tensor it could could live in
different ambient
spaces and so we perform direct Thum we
perform tensor product and
third uh important tensor beside the
matx multiplication tensor will just be
this diagonal tensor yeah so this is um
you just uh take the space k to the r
and this is essentially the the
threedimensional identity Matrix you
just take this this this box and you
just have once on the diagonal from one
corner to the opposite corner
and
um what we want to do is now we want to
um compare um the complexity of such
tensors and this is done by restrictions
so we have a tensor T and we have a
tensor T prime one lives in the vector
space u tens v t w and the other one
lives in the T Vector space u Prime t v
Prime t w Prime and then we call T a
restriction of T Prime if we can find
homomorphisms from U Prime to U and V
Prime to W and W Prime to w w such that
t
um is this thing take the tensor product
of these three homomorphisms and apply
to T Prime essentially this just means
that um you can write T Prime as a
decomposition of Triads these are
vectors and you can to every three
components of this Tri you apply the
homomorphism a b or c in particular if T
is a restriction of T Prime the rank of
T is less than T Prime
and you call T and T Prime
isomorphic um if you can choose a b and
c to be isomorphisms and then if they
isomorphic they are algorithmically
equivalent not even algorithmically but
also also
structurally
um if two tensors are isomorphic then
essentially from metical point of view
they have the same
structure but um if you think you take a
tensor T and you're just embedded in
some larger tensor and you just p with
zeros algorithmically this should be the
same tensor right because you just have
added some zeros and did nothing else
but of course mathematically they are
different objects because they live in
different
spaces and so this is why we need this
concept of
equivalence so you call a tensor t a
null tensor if it's just filled with
zeros if you have some space where it
LIF in and you have to just a zero
tensor into
space and
then we talk
call two tensors t and t Prime
equivalent we not it by this sign here
if we can find n tensor n and n Prime
such that the direct thms are
isomorphic you can think of if you have
these tensors we pet them they might
live in different spaces but we pet them
with zeros such that they have the same
size and then we have the the spaces
they live and have the same size and
then we have to find an isomorphism
between these two
ters and equivalent tens of they are
equivalent from an algorithmic point of
view they essentially have the same
complexity all the same
structure and it's fairly easy to see
that if s is a restriction of T then the
rank of s is
a bounded by the rank of T and um if s
is equivalent to T then the rank of both
is the same because then you have
restriction from s to T and restriction
from T to
S um here's another way of of defining
equivalence namely by by looking at what
is called a consise version of a tensor
so whenever you have a tensor T then
there's a unique
space have a tensor
T which Liv in U tensor V tensor W then
you can find the unique space
UT W so T is maybe not
good
C
size WC
so that t lives in this space and this
has a minimum Dimension so this is a
Subspace of this thing yeah and when you
um choose U see we VC and wc having the
same Dimension then two tensors are
equivalent if um the conest versions are
isomorphic and that's an equivalent
definition and important thing what I
want to do here now is when you think
about the tenser rank problem you want
to produce absolute statements about
tensors yeah you want to write something
like the rank of this tensor is bounded
by 123 or something like this what we
are doing here we are just producing
relative statements we want to have
something like this the rank of the one
tensor is bounded by the rank of another
tensor so this is these are the
statements that we want to produce but
it will turn out that we also get
absolute statements out of it because if
you choose this tensor T here to be this
diagonal one can show that the T of a
restriction of a diagonal if and only if
the rank is of a diagonal of size R if
only if the rank is bounded by R can you
recall the definition of between t what
definition
of just previous he wants to see the
previous slide see the previous slide
again
restriction
restriction but if you can f
one
okay
and
um so and um what we do now is
essentially we we form some semi ring
yeah so the elements in the semi ring
are our equivalence
classes of all the tens of that are
equivalent and then the addition in the
Sim ring this is just a you take the two
equivalence classes you two take two
Representatives you form the direct sum
of these representatives and you take
the equivalence class again
and the same you can do uh for
multiplication and multiplication is
essentially tensor product and then
because you have all these laws about
direct sum and tensor product you see
that this forms a sem
ring and so the the equivalent class of
the null tensor or of the diagonal of of
size zero that's a n null tensor this is
the neutral element for addition and the
diagonal of size one that's a neutral
element for multiplication that these
are just a simple calculation
and
um then it is quite easy to see that in
a standard way how is one defined if you
have different size uvw what do you have
defined this element one yes how is it
defined when you have just enlarge the
spaces so I guess just enlarge the
spaces so just P
just is notion of equ the diagonal
element with all the
bases yeah just the notion of equivalent
where we we just look at equivalent we
can always
pet and we can extend this
um to commentative ring in some standard
way yeah so we have the same
multiplication law we
know if s and t are the same then s and
t are
equivalent and for all A and B you can
find s and t such that you can write a
as the difference of two equivalence
classes
that's essentially the same construction
when you construct the integers out of
the natural numbers that's the same
construction what you need to work is uh
the following observation so we have you
have have if you have a decomposition
T
um into
um you can write
T any semi group can be extended to a
group that's what you're doing this is I
think
called exct inject and that's why you
need to have this canceling
the other
other what I need here is that um if it
is this decomposition so if I have one
such
composition there's another
decomposition these things are in
indecomposable in the sense if I can
write them as the sum of two different
elements one of them has to be n tensor
yeah then these two compositions are
essentially the same in the following
sense that R equals q and this is a
permutation of that so this is what you
need to make everything work and but
this is just you can just do the
calculations this is for the B+ not for
B that's for B I need it for B plus and
I need it for B so I need for both okay
no no but for B it will not be
unique
FOC it's not clear that if you take the
tensor product the product that you have
something like Prime tensors
that
composition not for it's just for the
addition just for the addition yes just
for the addition I don't need it for for
multiplication it's not
clear multiplication it's not clear but
it just need it for
addition this is a this this is a
statement and because this is true this
is a true statement and but I need it
for the
construction no no no R this what this
thing here what what which
r r is just you have a tensor T and you
can write it as this sum you write it as
a sum of indecomposable
tensors and indecomposable mean that you
cannot write these as as as a sum yeah
so these
are you clim this always and for T this
is
unique if if these T are Inc composable
in the sense that you cannot write them
as a sum again as a sum as a non-trivial
sum
I
think get unique and because it's Unique
this construction
works well you always get constructure
but they're having certain properties
you need yeah I can do the construction
but I would to have the properties that
I want I need this this uh so what would
happen if the UN Fails Like if somebody
produces forense two non equivalent de
composition then then s s the equivalent
class of s close when they're not
equivalent you can
collapse
the construction work but I need
essentially want to have this because
there all these algorithmic properties
underlying this because in the end you
also want to have algorithmic
statements and of course this B has also
Universal properties so when there's
another ring then you can break a
bracket and detect us through some
anisms or all the usual stuff
yeah so maybe sorry sure because if if R
is greater than the generic rank for the
tensor expected the in many compositions
into no no no it's direct sum it's
direct
sum it's not we are not adding just
taking direct some
that's it's just block decomposition no
nothing no no no no no
no yeah and
um so as I said before um What mo makes
this ring interesting essentially so if
R is a restriction of the diagonal of
size R then the rank is bounded by r of
T yeah so this this is essent this is
always the question that we have in mind
here yeah this is what we want to study
so um we should always ask ourselves is
this useful what we're
doing and um because if s is a
restriction of T and T is a restriction
of S and S and T are equivalent and if
the equivalence class of two tensors is
the same then they are equivalent um
restriction and
rank extend to B yeah so you we from now
on we will just just forget about our
tenders we just look at equivalence
classes and then just treat them uh as
they were
tenders and um then restriction this is
a partial order on this ring
B+ um which induces the natural order on
the the natural order and the natural
numbers yeah in particular this ring has
characteristic zero because essentially
these diagonals here they play the role
of the natural
numbers and then it takes some work to
verify this so if but are just some
calculations of a is a restriction of b
and a prime is a restriction of B Prime
you can add these two inequalities and
you can multiply these two
inequalities and so so this is again
essentially this is a direct sum of
tensors and this is tensor
multiplication but when I'm thinking
about Ring elements I will just write it
like
this and a third important property that
one is
that um this ring is archimedian in the
following sense so a exactly exactly yes
um
yeah so don't need this no this this one
here this is wrong this is wrong I don't
need it this is a typo I don't need that
so if you just have any tensor A and B
is a nonzero tensor then you can find
the natural number R such that a is
bound R *
B A should be positive so a should be in
B+ so H should be greater than zero yeah
yes and then so
yeah and um that's quite easy to see
because if B is a nonzero tensor you can
always degenerate one M multiplication
out of it and then because the rank of
any tensor is bounded by some R yeah you
just take this
R and we also can always do um uh so
restriction is invariant under
permutations of the the three
spaces and um
you can also view this as a very in a
very um abstract way so with archimedian
orders and and positive cones so
whenever you have um some ring a
commutative ring B you call some subset
p a positive cone if it closed under
multiplication if it's closed um under
addition if um zero and one are in P but
minus one is
not Phantom you can call this this per
call it a pre-ordered ring and
essentially um you induce a pre-order in
natural way so um a is less than b if
and only if B minus a is contained in
p and again in this case the ring B has
characteristic zero particular if I take
p and intersected with the the integers
I get n and because I just can take one
I add it up and that never will get
minus one because otherwise minus one
would be in P so I um create all the the
natural
numbers and then um we call P
archimedian for all A and B there is an
r and N such that R minus a is uh in P
so R is an upper Bound for
a in this case I can always write b as P
minus
P because um this upper bound R is
always contained in n and then I can
just write
a I can just write any element as a
minus r
R minus Rus a so that's how I write it
and um what you can also show that um in
this case the intersection of p and
minus p is an ideal and you can factor
out and then you would get an ordered
ring but shouldn't you require that P
somehow generates P otherwise I can have
a very small p and then it will not
satisfy this
properly I think right see you want P to
be generating B I want B to be generated
by P minus exactly exactly yeah yes that
that's that's got to be in there
what well well well if if you don't have
any restriction on P for instance say
say just the natural numbers inside of
ring would satisfy that and then
you you you wouldn't you wouldn't get
all that you need from archimedian you
would you need I need aredian I need
archimedian so this only holds if I have
aredian here I get
just archimedian implies this
implies this General pre- here here just
get a pre-order there does not hold
yeah you can have an
order exactly okay
okay so we essentially we have now this
restriction order and they have um this
just just this abstract order given by
this positive cones and then it's an
observation you see this I don't
know I wanted to look it up I forgot
yeah um
so ah okay so there's essentially no
positive cone in B that induces our
restriction order yeah so you have to so
this a positive con induces some order
this but this is the order which is our
restriction order which we def find in
the beginning and you can show that
there's no positive cone in B that
induces the um restriction order in
B+ and here's a count example so this is
a 2X 1X one matrix multiplication it has
rank two and one for those who not very
familiar with B+ is a is a cone right a
is cone B+ is a semi ring B+ is our
semi- ring that we constructed in the
beginning of all the tensors of all the
tensor classes is it like positive or
it's not positive cone is a way to
generate order this order cannot be so
the the positive cone we are looking for
a positive cone which lives inside B+
yeah inside B yeah
we're looking for some positive com
which is inside B and B contains B+
because this is this extension to a
ring yeah so for instance then um
because these two equations hold uh you
can multiply
them and um then you get that two
* this tensor plus two * that tensor is
bounded by four plus this tensor here
because by the property that if I take a
2 by 1 by one matrix multiplication 1 by
2x1 matrix multiplication get a 2X 2x1
matrix multiplication and thenone can
show that these Matrix sorry that these
Matrix multiplications are in
composable then here on the left hand
side I have four indecomposable parts
and there should be a restriction of
five indecomposable parts and that
cannot
happen so
um um we cannot um find some positive
cone in B that induces this restriction
order and therefore um we relax this
restriction order to Asm totic
can we just take a second to tell us
what you're going to I mean you're
introducing all this formalism you have
not told us why yeah because um in the
end I want to use some uh representation
theorem by kis Stone and du which
essentially you need rings and you need
some positive archimedian Coe in this R
and what are you going to you prove with
the use of this St
there so I
want get some representation on this I
can study the exponent of matrix
multiplication are you going to prove
lower bounds upper bounds just
structural structural theorems
structural theorems structural theorems
insides insides So currently we are only
producing insides nothing else
okay
number
very also insights in the algorithms
because all the equations that I will
let on they all correspond to
algorithms what do you mean by format
format is um the dimension of the spaces
uh it's an eight dimensional space
sensor right that's the format
yeah that's
a and um yeah so um s yeah sure sure
sure so um why can I not go from 5 to
four incompatible block structure it is
a block structure and if I have five I
think the argument is you have
restriction but both sides have the same
format so because they are conis they
are is they are
isomorphic okay that's so but then you
have this uniqueness or of this dis
position so they would have to have the
same yeah so it cannot be have to be
isomorphic because the format is the
same but they have a different uh number
of terms in it's Unique
decomposition why did they because oh
because the original 21 one is is not
less than or equal to two but equal to
two no no no no it's not equal it's not
equal to two because I don't know if the
bracket equals bracket no that mean that
degenerated diagonal of size 2x two of
this oh this is that two is the 2 two
two two no that two this is just a
diagonal of first two okay the bracket
that two us be call bracket bracket two
yeah so because we forget about because
there are the natural numbers that I
find in my
ring but 2211 is not bracket to tensor
bracket 211 this a symmetric
multiplication T off H it's symmetric
multiplication T off no
two bracket 211 and bracket that's just
two copies no no that's two copies
that's just a scal multiple okay
fine therefore we um relax
this to um ASM totic degeneration yeah
so we say s is an ASM totic ASM totic
restriction not degeneration is an ASM
totic
restriction if I take a huge T power of
s
I can restrict this from a huge 10 the
power of T but not one but I have a
subexponential number of copies that's
the usual thing that you you find
whenever you do produce fast Matrix Al
multiplication algorithms for instance
by by by transforming border rank into
rank you get all you get the stuff and
then you would take n roots of square
roots and asically this thing would go
away and then so that's that's what what
lies behind all the the modern or all
the more sophisticated fast matrix
multiplication is asmic restriction
that's but it makes sense to introduce
this thing here right because there's an
algorithmic uh concept underlying
it in particular uh if you can prove
that say some matrix multiplication is
an ASM totic restriction of some
diagonal then the rank of the thing is
bounded by so you get an upper bound of
the exponent like you would if you just
would bound the rank in exactly the same
way yeah so ASM for for for bounded
exponent ASM totic restriction is as as
just an upper bound of the rank for
something yeah and then you can show
that um this um thing has uh all this
this nice properties that I want to have
like before like restriction and that's
just as side remark it also implies
degeneration so
that that's again yeah that's again
wrong so somehow this is a copy paste I
just copy it and just replace the
symbols automatically yeah it's exactly
the same error
so so what's this triangle last triangle
that's um degeneration so that's
essentially the relative version of
Border rank okay or I think Chris will
explain it later on you can yeah here
here you can just state that f is
contained inm and one is closure under
GL one is correct action of
endomorph that's not important here just
just that's just a
side and
now
I can show that whenever I can
write some a so this is just some some
prelim stuff so if I can write a as two
compositions so a lives in my ring B I
can write it in two ways then I can show
that A1 is a um ASM totic restriction of
A2 if and only if B1 is an ASM totic
restriction of B2 and now I'm defining
what is called the ASM totic cone so I
take all the A's and B such that I can
write a as A1 minus A2
such that A2 is a restriction of A1 so
essentially these are somehow this is
posit something something positive yeah
A2 is less than A1 and I'm taking the
differences and this thing contains the
whole ring of tensors that we B+ andone
can show that this is an archimedian
positive cone so you have to prove this
once you have this and of course this
cone um induces um this restriction on
mat classes so the first LMA is what is
interesting because it shows that you
can extend this Astic order to the whole
yes that's important so this is this did
not work for restriction but it works
for ASM totic restriction that's an
important LMA that's very important it
should be read yeah okay no but it's not
it's equality there not less than equ no
no this this just means if I can write
a and two WI
then as a difference then one the
left
that's now I have
everything I need a last property namely
what is called a stone
pre-order and this is just this
uh so this is the property which you
need essentially the proof because um
for what we will do on the next slide so
um I call something a stone pre-order
sorry if for every A and B
I take an A and B and I suppose that for
All N I can find a p in N such if I take
Take N copies of a I add one and then I
can multiply this by some p and I land
in my positive asmic cone then already a
has to be in this
cone this is called a stone pre-order I
will not tell you for what we will need
it it's essentially needed in the proof
of the next theorem and an acuma acum
Stone pre- where was
preorder this is this will always give
order cone and order is not the
same some intuition I mean assume we
could just divide by integers then P * a
+ n a greater thanal Z then you divide
then it means 1 / n+ a greater
Z this is some continuity
so want to prer that a I think that's
the
ination just make we we saw if I
understand correctly three main par here
yes and you're going to concentrate on
this one Astic one I'm going to take ASM
totic restriction yes which is induced
by an asmic
cone
and such thing which in addition uh
fulfill the stone uh condition is called
a stone pre-order or stone
cone and
then and then so this this is what we
now worked so now in this situation we
have this we have this ring B this
conative ring B and in this ring we have
this stone cone we can apply this this
structure theorem by Stone kis and
Dua and here's just formulated for
tensor for our tensor ring but it works
for any ring which fulfills this
property yeah so if I have any Sim ring
of
tensors or subsi ring sub ring or subsi
ring a subsi ring yeah subsi ring we
just it's a subsi ring yeah sorry then
access some compact space and the
homomorphism high from our semi ring
into this uh into the uh these are now
the continuous
functions positive continuous functions
on this this compact space here such
that five of a separates the points of
this space which means when I have two
different points I will find a function
which has different values on these
points
and for all A and B and S A is a
restriction or asmic restriction of B if
and only if F of a is upper bounded by F
of B on the whole comple
space and just remember so this thing
here is just something which has
something about 10 or just astoic
restrictions yeah so if you now think a
little bit of this is an amazing theorem
the first glance is an amazing theorem
yeah because forget about tensors forget
about algebra forget about everything
all you have to do is you have to just
to study functions continuous functions
on a complex bace that's calculus the SP
right so that that's sort of do yeah no
yeah that's that's the problem that's
that's the problem yeah that's exactly
the problem a real version the exactly
that's exactly exactly that's what I was
think but ear Ian you st full generality
so this
realization form
of what is
necessary you just need ative even so
just even works for non-com Rings you
just have to need a ring and you need an
um a stone in
it
what very
complicated we know anything about this
this this is exactly the problem so
Delta from for matx multiplication I can
tell you about something about Delta um
but the point is though the well you
know Delta if and only if you know the
exponent of matrix multiplication that
it this will
be this will be the the story yeah so
particular like real spectrum of that
ring you have to know something about
structure to sa but I think there is
more information Omega is just for the
multiplication of square mates if you
look at multiplication of rectang matri
asally it is more that is some shape of
Delta which is also unknown but there's
more information just one
number so you can you can of course you
well essentially we now look at uh fin
generated Rings sub rings of s so you
just you just St one can
you and then Fe becomes automatically
injected
right see because
there but you say unique up to canonical
homeomorphism but I can artificially
enlarge by Delta by multiplying Delta
across let's say r r is not but S1
doesn't
matter I can artificially multiply Delta
by S1 and I can what what what what what
what Ian Delta Delta is is the real
spectrum of this ring it's sort of
canonically defined by the ring yeah but
the way stated he didn't tell us what
canonical
means
exactly says what that remark means we
don't
know but he doesn't mean
that yeah
so no exactly no no I understand that no
no I definitely understand that that's
yeah so it's not everything
need to have the separation ofs we maybe
should we should maybe let him give his
talk no that's
okay so I skipped some of the details
which I want to come to some certain
point yeah but and uh but it's a long
way yeah so it the whole sequence of
papers had sever 100 and something pages
so I have to skip some have to be
imprecise in some uh some some some and
um so what do we know do essentially um
what we now want to do so we don't look
at the whole ring of
tensors but we just take some tensors so
you could just take the tens of 2x two
matrix multiplication if you take this
ring what does this ring generate so you
just take pols with natural coefficients
you can plug in the tensors for instance
you get all the tensors of of of format
um get all the tensors of this this this
format here
so so you can could just look at
uh at this this ring here so it's simply
generated by just this one t and it is
already tells you everything about the
ASM totic complexity of matrix
multiplication if you can't understand
this one yeah so this will be um the
ring that we will look
at and so essentially we can now um make
the our life a little bit more simpler
yeah so we
um essentially we take now a continuous
map from our our space to R to the Q
here it would be just R we just map some
element Z to five of A1 which is a
function and we just plug in that so
therefore we um essentially can embed
the ASM totic Spectra in some R to the Q
where Q if I have a finite number of
generators is a finite number in
particular here would just be one this
is an injective
map this is compact um this map is a
hopis on its image so we take this IM
image I can take the inverse
homomorphism and
then well if I take the composition here
this is an uh asmic spectrum of s in a
particular um f Prime of AJ which is the
J's generator of my ring this is just
the the J's coordinate
function and
um so this thing I call the embedded
asmic spectrum of of this thing here
it's contained in r2d Q as I said if I
restrict F of AJ is the coordinate
function restricted to my
space
um if I have um P inm of Q um if and
only if p is bounded by Q on my my my
space for any integer Pol norals p and
Q and um the same is also true for
restrict
but the converse here does not hold and
I can also describe my my my my space
here in some some abstract way because
it's just um the set of all equations
that hold when a p of uh this thing is
the Restriction of Q of this thing so
these are tens of
here because I know if AJ is non zero
that one is a lower Bound for AJ and the
rank is an upper bound I also know that
this thing here is contained in this uh
this space so it's contained in some
Q
but also know if I just take the format
here of my my AJ then um the
corresponding vectors are also contain
the Spectrum which are called G
points okay so here's an example
so what do I know I just take my my ring
here so I only have one coordinate here
and I take a logarithmic and so there a
j standing here but here I only have one
so I take a logarithmic embedding of my
my my coordinates I will write my
coordinates not as X but as 2 to the to
J so we just scale them
logarithmically and then
um I know that five of 222 this is just
two to the
tower because I have only one coordinate
in this ring I will get this thing they
can just draw this polinomial
here starts by or this function here it
starts by three it ends here somewhere
and here it's um well it has unique zero
and that's just 2.81 something so what
is this what do I'm doing I'm just just
want to find something out about the
asmic Spectrum by looking at Stu's
algorithm and what I know this
polinomial or this fun this continuous
function
here 7us 2 to the X yeah that's the
that's the function 7us 2 to the x or 2
to the what I'm looking it so that's
that that's that's
the so what what have I learned by
looking at this picture what have I
learned by looking at this picture you
learned that the asmic Spectrum cannot
have point on this this range here
because the function is negative there
but I know the function has to be
positive on the ASM totic Spectrum so
translated into what I learned new about
matrix multiplication that I had not
know before so this picture so far you
didn't learn anything you
okay Le not about matrix multiplication
not about matrix multiplication well
what have I learned about anything out
outside of the
form all right I'm criticizing you guys
doing the same thing okay continue you
get extra minutes uh I don't I can also
just go on in the evening if somebody is
interested
um virtual tensor so the point is if I
now want to also talk about 3x3 Matrix
multiplic so I want to talk about these
tensors I would have to add them as
generators there and uh
maybe this thing
one also example you get another
equation yeah so the point of everything
is you can also interpret all the equ
all the equations the algorithms that
you have and equations on the Spectrum
and it then it's uh non-rival to prove
so that the ASM totic spectrum of of
matrix multiplication that's really the
interval
between uh yeah so it's between four and
2 to the Omega or if you want to look at
at it logarithmically between between
two and
Omega of course like I said the
pessimistic view of this is of course um
I didn't learn anything new about matrix
multiplication so to determine this
thing here I need to know Omega what
about but you can also look at it
optimistically yeah because now stronger
M mathematical tooth might be aailable
might be Avail might might be available
for instance say you can prove a a such
a ring it's generated by one1 it's
simply generated it has a certain
property maybe the tensor is tied or
whatever and then I can prove that the
ASM totic spectrum is always a
point looks like a perfect reasonable
abstract thing it has nothing to do with
matrix multiplication but
then yeah I would get that the exponent
is two from such such a
statement this gives you a Machinery to
think about this problem without having
matrix multiplication in mind that's
maybe the strongest thing because in
mrix multiplication I have the feeling
we are stuck we don't know any new we
don't know any new of these equations
here so well we have some new ones but
they well they they don't hit the line
here but they hit it little bit more
there yeah but but nothing else is has
happened during the last 20 years so
this is
um
uh what
um what in my opinion makes this asmic
spectrum interesting this giv an
abstract way to think about matrix
multiplication without having it in
mind
interpret the group theoretic approach
have funny
functions just one thing so so far this
was trust's
work
uh yeah maybe so what we I what man and
I here proposes another kind of
restriction which is stronger because it
you get more algorithms out of
it so
um I call S to be an ASM totic dis joint
copy restriction of T if so the right
hand side is the same I have a
subexponential number of uh copies of t
to the N but on left hand side I don't
have now s to the
N but I just get a bunch of copies of s
out of a smaller
power the only restriction that I have
is I have Epsilon to the end many
copies of one of powers of of of order
1us Epsilon to the N for any fixed
Epsilon which just has to be between
bounded away from one so that's the
important
thing and this here is just the size of
this tens are here to make the
dimensions are accessing
match and obviously that this
implies uh this this new restriction
implies the old restriction and for
diagonals they are the same so I get a
natural number so I can do the whole
theory of stone pre-orders and I get the
same spectral theorem for
this and um the question is of course
why is is useful no so this one should
be Spectrum no I get a different
Spectrum no in the end it will be the
same because they will just contain one
point but I don't KN know to how to
prove
this at the end it will just contain a
point two yeah that's
a that's the religious belief that they
people that's maybe the religious belief
yeah but I don't
know so why is this useful essentially
um yeah so
um if
say
uh you have you can Define now this this
new exponent which is a relative notion
but you can Define it and what
essentially get is you get an inequality
like this yeah so the the original the
old
exponent is bounded by this this new
exponent of matrix multiplication minus
2 Epsilon over 1 minus Epsilon if have
this restriction
here and if you
believe that say this expon if you can
prove that this exponent is two you also
get that the old exponent is two if you
get something larger then you lose
something
yeah and so the conclusion yeah so also
this restriction is stronger so you can
have more algorithmic tools at your hand
you can still say something useful about
the exponent if it's two so where why is
this where comes this from this is
inspired um by this this concept that Co
humans in the soda 2012 yeah lastly um
it's this of support rank what they have
there yeah and so they say that um a
tensor uh the support rank of a tensor
bounded by R if the two tensors have the
same ranks you will talk about this yeah
okay yeah and essentially what you can
show if the support rank of something is
bounded by R then this tensor a is uh
this D
restriction of of the diagonal of size R
so that's essentially the important
concept lying behind this modul some
technical side condition that you have
here which I will not beine because I'm
already out of time okay so that's uh it
from my side
I somewhat overtime but uh so we I I
guess we had already some of the
discussion during my talk so we maybe
can just should stop here thank you okay
thank
you we have many questions and comments
so is Delta something like a toic
variety can you take it to be like a
dir just
a yeah yeah but I'm
asking can you take I don't have I don't
know anything I have to we have to find
out everything about Delta yeah you know
it exists but then you have to do the
work for for each of the ring that
you're interested
in deter this some examples there are
examples
where so if you
for some tens if you look at this
algebra you take a Univar
pols modular sum polinomial and um so
for this complexity wise you know
everything about this for Rank and
Border rank um and also we can determine
the ASM totic spectrum of this
thing you also has some results about um
some prelimary results about ASM totic
spectrum of rectangular matrices there
we even don't know convexity for
instance
and even showing that this here in this
case it's an interval that's not trivial
yeah you really have to work for
this more questions
comments you're okay well I I don't well
I'll ask it now and you can decide
whether it needs to be taken offline so
can you give me a sequence of lemas any
LMA you want say three lemas that if you
could prove those then you could tell me
something new about matrix
multiplication using this
format
formalism any or you yeah I mean it's
reasonable that you might prove in your
lifetime because I don't see how this is
going to give insight into matrix
multiplication it's just it's kind of
seems to me you have a very concrete
object in replacing it by a more
abstract object that you can't even
identify so different geometry that's in
interes state so you should think but
it's
important perfectly happy but I'm
missing the punchline is what I'm saying
you can Pro ignorance my interpretation
of this is that that the theory tells
you that there exists a complete set of
monoton yes for for any pair of tensors
you want to
compare and now you can find and this
kind of gives you a way of describing
yeah he did not marus did not describe
it but there are things here that are
useful compation surpris
surprising okay I suggest we just take
this
offline analog operator are you are you
expecting this to leave BS or what do
what what's your Hope from this that's
what I don't
get
fine I mean you prove concrete bound
right concrete lower bound